the jogan experience I remember you tell
I remember you telling me a story how
you had been up all night and you you
got back to Mad TV had to get there for
something for some like was it a table
read or what and you had a giant knife
on you your superow and tweaking oh yeah
he said you had a he said you were
carrying like a Bowie knife yeah and
sometimes a Kling on one of those CL got
love Star Trek yeah so I had a Kling on
knife when the curve P was it it was
like this long I still have it by my b
right I was sticking right here right
and an open Hawaiian shirt and I was
breaking out and they that's what it
like that's what it looked like yeah
pretty dope that is actually pretty dope
that's what Klingons would carry on and
then they would uh is that crazy they
have spaces shs so they still need
knives it seems so like you don't have a
better you have weapon well first of all
they didn't even have the [__]
internet it's the dumbest show ever and
they had walkie-talkies they hadn't even
figured out phones yet I never thought
of that Kirk out click You' have to
right you think they would have like a
nothing yeah something yeah but yet they
could beam you up they literally take
your body and it's still a good show
it's a great show it's a it's still a
good SciFi show I love Star Trek next
Generation no first one the real one old
one I'm sorry i i s I'll back up I'm
sorry you're wrong I'm not wrong yeah
yeah can I just say something I can't be
wrong for liking something I understand
that I think that you're misinformed how
so because and and do me a favor season
five no all right I right now I know but
can I just just open your heart it's
open okay so may I say what I'm going to
say right may I yes please all right
season five okay second to the last
episode okay the episode's called Inner
Light I'm not going to watch it I'm not
asking you to but I'm ask I'm not asking
you to but I'm I'm not but I'm asking
your
fans to check it out yell at me that
episode is the greatest piece of sci-fi
ever
filmed and Adam eot hated Star Trek I
forced him to watch this episode he
watched every episode after that really
yeah okay I'll watch it's a great
episode okay I will watch it now I
changed my mind I watch it see your
heart was open it looks interesting It
looks interesting cuz he's walking
around and [__] okay see what he's got
to say maybe he's un like a A Vision
Quest no the concept is great okay yeah
yeah yeah I believe you okay good thank
you I like the old one just for
nostalgic purposes because I'm old and
because when I was a kid that was on
television and I remember watching Star
Trek Captain Kirk like oh my God he's
the coolest yeah it was the best you
know and and it was also it's so corny
like if you watch it today it's gone to
this point where it becomes funny it's
parody like there's a there's a scene
where Captain Kirk has a fight with a
like a lizard
man on a on a planet remember I remember
the dumbest fight scene ever it's right
up there with the sck $6 Million Man
versus Bigfoot that's the dumbest one
but this one's pretty dumb look how
handsome he was so handsome first of all
this lizard is so goddamn slow I would
[__] this lizard up I would [__] look at
this I would [__] him up I would [__]
look how slow he is bro I would [__] him
up I would be leg kicking him right now
w w I take them knees out oh that what a
shitty body kick wow he fight he fights
like Brendan sha a little bit but all he
did just throw him Bren sha was a good
fighter shut your mouth he knocked out
merco C I'm kid I'm kidding I'm kidding
I love him so look at this he's right
next to you and he's not even biting you
this this is the biggest [__] lizard of
all time he's not even biting yeah he's
not biting the is right there he's got a
giant mouth filled with teeth easily he
can bite there's no restraint keeping
him from biting yeah oh a Captain Kirk
he he hit him with the ears now he's oh
he hurt him with the ears so what does
he do he runs away like a [__] now he's
going to throw rocks at
him yeah you got to hit him in the ear
bro get close the guy's slow as
[__] look at him this is so dumb this is
so dumb this is so dumb it hurts my
feelings but imagine shooting that that
day it's so hot that guy in the lizard
suit oh my God God oh he's sweating his
dick off yeah he's having it rough cuz
that's probably Burbank or somewhere
those Stone like that totally looks like
it could be California doesn't it yeah
they they must have shot it oh he's
gonna pick up the rock look how fake
that rock looks watch she GNA throw that
rock all you have to do is just get out
of the way now don't stand there wait
for the look get out of the [__] way
bro oh Jes Christ what how casual did he
get out of the way cuz he knew it wasn't
a real rock yeah it reminds when
remember that guy threw the shoe at Bush
This is Picture Perfect terrible acting
yeah picture perfect terrible
choreography everything about it is
hilarious does it end that was it yeah
he doesn't kill him he ran away he ran
away yeah yeah how dumb throw Boulders
at him you get that I love that show
yeah it reminds me of old Godzillas you
remember when uh Captain Kirk hooked up
with that green lady it was a big deal
would you have yeah so I would have [__]
the Avatar ladies if you and I had a
like a the Avatar ladies that lady's hot
on Pandora I don't know it looks blue
the one I gives a [__] the one that he
eventually winds up with she's hot but
you know how like the creatures connect
with the tals or whatever then they
communicate yeah does that come out of
the vagina too I don't know I don't
think they have a
vagina oh I think you just link up like
that come in your mind you come oh yeah
I'd love to come in my mind who knows
how the babies even get there I can't
you know can
I they don't have I mean they they have
things over their dicks so they must
have dicks right they all had loin claws
yeah but I'm 52 Joe and I I can't I
can't I can't come you can't come I come
every other time every other time that's
good but you know I like I like edging
but how much are you [__] are you
trying to [__] every day or jerk off
every day maybe you're running out of
jizz maybe you just have a small Factory
you know and you're just demanding too
much out no my factory is pretty big
dude your balls are big for my size yeah
yeah but like for normal humans when you
hit 52 like how often are you coming
every other day that's reasonable that's
reasonable but when I'm in the sack with
a woman oh psychologically I can't do it
so do you just fake it I I pull on her
no I make I the
yeah and I do it back I go back you go
back so there yeah so I go and I'll go
back the back to the wall good move in
the dark oh and act it out ground I act
I'm a good actor righty right right and
I go straight to the bathroom like I'm
washing it whoa so they can't see the
come that's a good move thank you it's a
good move you want to be
deceptive yeah
yeah